ya se conoce la identidad de un
sospechoso de aaron brooks de 39 años
que está en custodia policial y de quien
conocemos y ha trascendido su historial
criminal con abuso doméstico resistencia
a la autoridad entre otros en cuanto a
las víctimas algunas de estas víctimas
mortales es una anciana del grupo de
baile que participaba en ese desfile
llamado tenzing grannis las abuelas
bailarinas que han lamentado en su
propia página de facebook la pérdida de
una de sus integrantes también muchos
niños en la lista de heridos ya que es
una celebración familiar la que se
estaba viviendo aquí mismo en estas
calles que ahora mismo se están
limpiando justo el cordón policial se
acaba de limitar y ya tenemos acceso a
la prensa a poder estar en este sitio
donde se presentan personas para mostrar
su tristeza y para hacer ofrendas
florales incluso esta tarde está
prevista un memorial y sin duda esta
ciudad está trágicamente sufriendo la
que ha sido un episodio muy conmovedor
por la connotación familiar
y porque siempre una tragedia de estas
características pues duele muchísimo en
una comunidad pequeña